said he could close that in 24 hours if
he wanted to do you think he could I
have no idea I mean he couldn't build a
border wall in four years so you know
there is a gap between promises and
delivery with all politicians very much
including him but I will say in Trump's
defense and maybe because he's a little
bit autistic he saw the stakes of this
like at the very beginning he's like you
don't want and this is what I do love
about Trump particularly in foreign
policy he sees the big stuff he's like
wait
you've got Russia in China they don't
trust each other we can't let them get
together but they'll kick our ass and
we'll be not We're not gonna fight a war
against them one hopes but we'll
definitely be taking orders from them
it's not just that Trump had the right
instincts on this stuff it's that our
current leadership either have no idea
what they're doing or are intentionally
trying to destroy our our alliances
wreck the economy etc etc